Transcription: Yuhan ZHANG
Relecteur: eric vautier
Imaginez.
Si vous perdiez le sens de l’odorat,
vous seriez anosmique.
On estime que l’anosmie ou l’hyposmie
va toucher en moyenne
entre 3 et 20% de la population.
Il y a donc parmi vous, ce soir,
des personnes qui sont
anosmiques et hyposmiques.
Ce trouble olfactif peut être causé
par des maladies neurodégénératives,
des maladies chroniques,
mais également des infections
des voies respiratoires supérieures.
Et ces infections,
elles peuvent être causées
notamment par des virus.
(Rires)
Les personnes affectées
par ce fameux virus
vont alors développer
des troubles de l’odorat.
La vie est un enfer pour ces personnes-là.
Pourquoi ? Imaginez, vous ne pouvez plus
sentir la fumée d’un départ de feu.
Vous ne pouvez plus sentir un aliment
impropre à la consommation,
risquant une intoxication alimentaire.
Vous êtes privé d’un sens crucial
pour votre vie et votre survie.
En effet, trop peu de gens
ont conscience
de l’éventail d’informations
qui sont fournies par l’odorat.
Nous pouvons, grâce à l’odorat,
non seulement détecter des odeurs nocives
dans notre environnement,
mais aussi apprécier énormément
de moments agréables de notre vie,
comme la dégustation d’un bon repas,
une balade en forêt, et
les petites fleurs sur le petit sentier,
ou un moment d’intimité
avec son partenaire.
Sans l’olfaction, vous êtes privé
de tous ces bons moments.
Vous mettez votre vie en danger
et vous avez une qualité de vie dégradée.
Exercer votre odorat,
connaître votre odorat,
c’est connaître votre état de santé.
L’olfaction est au centre
de mes recherches.
Au laboratoire,
nous essayons de comprendre
comment l’organe olfactif
se crée, se forme
en utilisant l’embryon pour comprendre
comment il peut être affecté
et comment il y a
des problèmes chez l’adulte.
En comprenant l’embryon,
nous pouvons comprendre
et apporter des éléments de réponse
à certaines pathologies olfactives
chez l’adulte.
La recherche fondamentale est utile,
parce qu’elle nous permet
de comprendre les processus embryonnaires.
Pourquoi ? Imaginez un organisme vivant
comme une maison.
Dans une maison, vous avez chaque élément
et chaque élément a une fonction.
La cuisine, c’est pour préparer le repas,
la chambre à coucher, c’est pour dormir
et le salon pour regarder la télévision
ou vous prélasser.
L’organisme vivant, un être humain,
a deux yeux, un nez pour sentir,
une bouche et deux oreilles pour entendre.
La majorité des organismes vivants
sont comme cela.
Le poisson zèbre, le petit poisson,
a la même architecture.
Mais revenons à l’embryon.
L’embryon, c’est la maison
en construction.
Si vous avez une fuite dans votre maison,
mieux vaut avoir prévu
les plans des canalisations
pour pouvoir réparer cette fuite.
Connaître l’embryon,
c’est avoir toutes les notices
de ce qui pourrait se passer
dans votre maison pour pouvoir la réparer.
Donc, chez l’adulte.
Au laboratoire, nous utilisons le poisson
zèbre pour comprendre l’humain.
Pourquoi ? Imaginez l’être humain.
L’être humain, c’est une maison
très complexe, un manoir, un château.
Il nous faut des maisons
un peu plus simples,
qui ont la même architecture
et sur lesquelles on pourra
travailler plus facilement,
comme des organismes modèles.
Une maison en bois, par exemple,
qui est plus simple.
C’est le célèbre petit poisson zèbre.
Nous étudions donc l’olfaction.
Et la recherche fondamentale est utile,
parce qu’elle nous permet
de réutiliser des découvertes du passé
et de leur donner un nouveau sens.
[La Méduse et la GFP]
Dans les années 1960,
un Japonais, Osamu Shimomura,
a découvert une propriété particulière
de la méduse Aequorea Victoria.
Cette méduse fluoresçait en vert,
elle exprimait la GFP -
Green Fluorescent Protein –
comme un stabilo vert.
Pendant 30 ans, cette découverte
a été une pure curiosité.
Elle n’a servi à rien.
On ne savait même pas ce que cette GFP,
cette Green Fluorescent Protein,
apportait à la méduse.
Maintenant, on sait qu’elle lui
sert à éloigner ses prédateurs.
Mais dans les années 90,
d’autres chercheurs,
Martin Chalfie et Roger Tsien,
ont eu la fabuleuse idée
de marquer des cellules.
Je vous explique.
Vous pouvez, avec votre stabilo vert,
fluorescer des lignes et des lignes
sur une page blanche.
Si vous fluotez des lignes
ou des mots dans un texte,
vous pouvez les voir,
vous pouvez les suivre,
et c’est la fantastique idée
que ces chercheurs ont eue.
Grâce à cette protéine de la méduse,
la GFP,
on peut suivre des populations cellulaires
et maintenant, on peut suivre
chez l’embryon de poisson zèbre
comme un GPS, à Toulouse,
le positionnement
de ses cellules olfactives
et on peut savoir d’où elles viennent
et où elles vont arriver.
En comprenant ce trajet,
cette notice olfactive,
on peut mieux comprendre l’olfaction.
Vous voyez comment une découverte
faite dans les années 60,
qui n’avait aucun intérêt,
a eu un prix Nobel en 2008
et est réutilisée maintenant
en biologie cellulaire,
en biologie moléculaire,
pour comprendre le GPS d’une cellule.
Elle sert également à suivre
des cellules cancéreuses
et à comprendre comment
elles vont effectuer des métastases
pour coloniser d’autres organes.
La biologie est
un fantastique carrefour central
entre différentes disciplines :
les mathématiques, la physique,
la mécanique et l’informatique.
En effet, dans les années 1900,
D’Arcy Thompson a montré
que des lois physiques et mathématiques
permettaient la forme des êtres vivants.
Le fantastique mathématicien Alan Turing,
dans les années 1950,
a théorisé les systèmes
d’équations diffusion
qui nous servent à expliquer
les patrons de léopards sur leur dos,
ou les rayures sur un poisson zèbre.
Et enfin, dans les années 80,
plus près de nous,
la fantastique Leah Edelstein-Keshet,
a donné à tous les biologistes
toute la base des modèles biomathématiques
pour expliquer le vivant.
Au final,
la recherche fondamentale est utile.
Elle vous permet de comprendre
la formation des êtres vivants
en utilisant l’embryon pour comprendre
ce qui se passe chez l’adulte.
Elle nous permet
d’accumuler des connaissances.
Des fois, il n’y a aucune application
à l’instant t.
Mais des années,
voire des années plus tard,
il y a une fonction
et peut-être un prix Nobel.
Pensez à la GFP.
La prochaine fois que vous aurez
une notice ou un mode d’emploi
pour fabriquer un appareil ou un meuble,
vous penserez à l’olfaction,
vous penserez à la méduse
et vous penserez à l’utilité
de la recherche fondamentale.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)